ty monsieur françois fillon pour le
groupe l'est républicain monsieur le
dimanche dernier la chancelière
allemande à l'occasion d'un déplacement
à istanbul a proposé au président
erdogan d'accélérer le processus
d'adhésion de la turquie à l'union
européenne en échange d'une meilleure
coopération sur la question des réfugiés
syriens
monsieur le premier ministre le
gouvernement français soutient-il cette
initiative est ce que madame merkel
parlait au nom de l'union européenne
et si ça n'est pas le cas est ce que le
gouvernement français a demandé des
explications à la chancelière allemande
madame merkel en effet ne peut pas après
avoir grand ouvert les portes de
l'allemagne et donc d'une certaine
manière de l'europe pour réfugiés sans
la moindre concertation avec ses
partenaires tenter de rattraper cette
erreur en proposant un marchandage sur
une adhésion de la turquie à l'union
européenne qui n'est ni possible ni
souhaitable
depuis depuis 2005 grâce notamment à
l'initiative du président chirac
un référendum est nécessaire pour
valider toute adhésion nouvelle à
l'union européenne en france et donc
chacun sait que le moment venu la france
opposera son veto à l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'union européenne dans ces
conditions je considère qu'il est
dangereux de laisser ce marchandage se
perpétuer la turquie est un grand pays
c'est un pays avec lequel l'europe doit
compter mais je pense que ce n'est pas
rendre service à la turquie ni à
l'europe d'ailleurs que de lui mentir
sur son avenir
monsieur le premier ministre est une
question essentielle c'est une question
qui concerne l'avenir du continent
européen et la civilisation européenne
je vous demande devant l'assemblée
nationale de clarifier la position de la
france
merci monsieur clients la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre votre et
manuel valls le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député monsieur françois
fillon la turquie
la turquie
m
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
la turquie monsieur le premier ministre
je des bases suffisamment avec françois
fillon et de manière courtoise pour vous
me permettiez de lui répondre c'est une
question lourde
c'est une question lourde les chers
collègues
mes chers collègues nous écoutons
monsieur le premier ministre
c'est une question lourde et je vais y
répondre précisément la turquie vous
l'avais dit à grand pays
c'est un partenaire stratégique de la
france et de l'union européenne
allié au sein de l'alliance atlantique
de l'otan'' depuis 1952 est engagé dans
un processus de rapprochement depuis
plusieurs années vous le savez avec
l'union européenne et qui se trouve au
coeur d'enjeux stratégiques majeures
notamment face au conflit syrien
elle est soumise à d'importantes
pressions pression du flux des réfugiés
elle accueille aujourd'hui sur son
territoire
plus de 2,2 millions de personnes
pression du terrorisme comme le drame
d'ankara l'a rappelé il y a quelques
jours et il faut que la turquie clarifie
par ailleurs ses objectifs par rapport à
ce qui se passe en syrie
le contexte politique en turquie est
sensible à la proche des élections
législatives du 1er novembre et nous
méconnaissons pas ni vous ni moi
personne ici le contexte et les débats
qui ont cours au sein de la société
turque
notre intérêt commun et je vous réponds
et de poursuivre le dialogue engagé
depuis plusieurs années maintenant et de
la soutenir dans l'effort qu'elle
fournit actuellement pour l'accueil des
réfugiés syriens
car si nous ne soutenons pas la turquie
et d'autres pays que je ne veux pas
oublier le liban et la jordanie
nous savons que la crise des réfugiés
que le connaissons en europe sera encore
plus dramatique est plus grave c'est
pourquoi le conseil européen du 15
octobre a décidé la mise en place d'un
plan d'action entre l'union européenne
et la turquie afin de renforcer notre
coopération pourquoi
pour garantir des conditions de vie
dignes et humaine aux réfugiés qui sont
accueillis sur le sol turc est de lutter
contre les réseaux de passeurs et de
renforcer le contrôle de nos frontières
extérieures en parallèle je réponds
l'union européenne apporte et apportera
également un soutien financier accru à
la turquie avec à la fois de l'aide
humanitaire et des fonds qui permettront
d'appuyer l'hébergement l'insertion
professionnelle et la formation des
réfugiés et c'est aide pour la turquie
je le répète elle est nécessaire
également pour le liban et pour la
jordanie la turquie vous avez dit je le
répète est un grand pays et nous le
savons quand il faut chercher une
solution pour la syrie nous avons besoin
vous rappeler souvent ne discutait avec
tous les grandes puissances et notamment
avec les pays voisins de la syrie dont
la turquie
cet engagement de l'europe est
indispensable et il ne modifie pas
cependant notre position vis-à-vis de la
turquie pour avancer sur la
libéralisation des visas ou sur le
processus de négociations d'adhésion en
tant que pays candidat car c'est un pays
candidat
la turquie est engagé dans une
négociation selon des règles qu'elle a
elle même accepté et nous souhaitons que
ces négociations avancent dans les
domaines sur lesquels la turquie est
prête comme vous le savez depuis 2005
quatorze chapitres sur 35 ont été
ouverts un a été fermé
onze de ces chapitres ont été ouverts
mais ce n'était pas votre question
sous la présidence de nicolas sarkozy
quand vous étiez premier ministre un
seul l'a été depuis l'arrivée de
françois hollande à la présidence de la
république
et comme l'a rappelé le chef de l'état
l'issue de ces négociations est ouverte
la question de l'adhésion turque reste
une perspective de long terme qui devra
moment venu être approuvée par le peuple
français donc il ne peut y avoir aucun
marchandage aucun chantage mais la
nécessité d'une aide à la turquie enfin
et je vous réponds aussi très
directement
monsieur fillon monsieur le premier
ministre l'allemagne est soumis un défi
considérable
c'est en grande partie mais pas
seulement c'est en grande partie son
choix la france est solidaire de
l'allemagne dans ces moments nous
n'avons pas la même approche
nous n'avons pas la même réponse nous ne
connaissons pas par ailleurs les mêmes
circonstances d'afflux de réfugiés
mais ici dans cette assemblée et parce
que c'est une constante de la politique
française
j'affirme que pour avancer en europe et
y compris pour apporter une réponse aux
problèmes que vous avez soulevés par
rapport aux défis des réfugiés mais bien
sûr par rapport à d'autres défis que
connaît l'europe la solidarité et le
lien avec l'allemagne sont
indispensables et je ne participerai pas
moi alors que madame merkel appartient à
la même formation politique que vous au
niveau européen le ppe
je ne participerai pas ici pour d'autres
raisons qui peut-être dépasse ce qui se
passe dans cet hémicycle à une mise en
cause de l'allemagne
c'est une constance et c'est un élément
important j'ai rappelé qu'elle était la
position de la france par rapport à la
turquie par rapport à son adhésion par
rapport à la constance mais ce lien et
cette solidarité avec l'allemagne nous
la revendiquons
c'est une constance nous en changeront
pas au gré des campagnes électorales
la parole est à m